[Music]
how did you have to get for this movie
and how hard did you work I work pretty
hard for this one um I think Ryan kind
of set me up because we set the bar so
high for creating so I try to be the
villain in this one you know I'm in a
superhero kind of world what's it like
being a bad guy no good kind of like
indulging in that side of you that that
if we did our job correctly he's a bad
guy that people can really empathize
with it kind of see his point of view
you know I feel like if you understand
him and understand and method to his
madness a little bit I think those would
make us make for the most interesting
villains to actually watch and I think
we I think I think we might have pulled
that off a lot of talking right now I'm
trending on Twitter it's Black Panther
soul it Ava Duvernay was just talking
about it how exciting is it that people
can't wait for this movie I think it's
also was very prideful man I've honestly
to be able to do a project like this you
know with this type of cast type of
talent these are you know with with
working with Ryan again and have the
entire community you know all walks of
life be excited about it I think I think
that's truly something special and how
what is the on your body
I saw the prosthetics there's some kind
of prosthetics on you what is that I
can't talk too much about that because
it kind of goes in the character a
little bit of story that I can't really
reveal to y'all yet but no is
significant so like who air kill mongers
yeah by the way how are you handling the
whole sex symbol thing I've never seen
any I'm gonna suggesting to this this
this this new air that I'm kind of
breathing in and in and it comes it's
balanced I'm trying to find a balance
man and I just turned 30 you know saying
in this general you know mature and
develop as a man and as an actor you
know I'm saying it from the screening
behind so it's cool man it's cool
mandolin okay my family's keeping me
grounded
yeah rescue been ground